où
elle aime lire vise bien entendu
c'est quelqu'un de formidable
très souriant et très serviable
je m'appelle et l'iseran ghoulam ans je
suis né le 30 janvier 1943 et j'ai trois
enfants
deux filles et un garçon et cinq petits
enfants j'étais enseignante jusqu'à 55
ans et quand j'ai pris ma retraite en
1998 je me suis consacré aux assauts aux
associations
on accompagne les familles on les aide à
faire leurs courses donc moyennant un
petit un petit passeport sur lequel il
ya un montant à respecter
c'est bon vous avez noté confiture n'est
pas prix n'a pas besoin
allez-y je me sens utile parce que j'ai
accompagné la famille et j'ai aidé un
petit peu géré le budget à varier
l'alimentation au début bon pensée
l'épicerie sociale seul parce que
c'était et au fil du temps ben on a bien
compris quoique bon les familles ont
besoin de laine donc
c'est important que l'on peut être à
leur écoute et les accompagner elle
répond toujours présente elle est
disponible depuis sa retraite vraiment
elle donne de son temps elle est très
dynamique et appréciez de et pour tout
ce qu'elle fait aussi pour les autres
hélas comme cet après midi j la danse
avec les 3e âge c'est un mélange c'est
un inter générationnelle on va dire donc
là je vais voir un petit peu bon où ça
en est quoi
si j'ai les dents ce qu'il faut
mais pas et une fois qu'il va rester en
place elle s'arrange pour être pour
vraiment rendre service aux autres
et et puis elle aime ça
le message que je voudrais faire passer
c'est c'est de ne pas hésité à
s'investir dans le monde associatif et
c'est important pour pour rendre heureux
les autres et nous aussi par là on a du
plaisir et de la joie d'annoncer que les
gens sont heureux